so I have an overlooked but potentially
lucrative investment opportunity for you
over the past 10 years in the UK the
return on burial plots has outperformed
the UK property market by a ratio of
around three to one there were private
cemeteries being set up with plots for
sale to investors and they started
around three thousand nine hundred
pounds and they're projected to achieve
about forty percent growth and the
biggest advantage is that this is a
market with continuous demand now this
is a real proposition and there are
companies out there that really are
offering this investment but my
interested in is is quite different I'm
an architect and urban designer and for
the past year and a half I've been
looking at approaches to death and dying
and at how they've shaped our cities and
the buildings within them so in the
summer i did my first exhibition on
death and architecture in venice and it
was called Death in Venice and because
death is a subject that many of us find
quite uncomfortable to talk about the
exhibition was designed to be quite
playful so that people would literally
engage with it so one of our exhibits
was an interactive map of London which
showed just how much of the real estate
in the city is given over to death and
as you wave your hand across the map the
name of the piece of real estate the
building or the cemetery is revealed and
those white shapes that you can see
they're all of the hospitals and
hospices and mortuaries and cemeteries
in the city in fact the majority of
cemeteries we wanted to show that even
though death and burial are things that
we might not think about they're all
around us and they're important parts of
our cities so about half a million
people die in the UK each year and of
those around a quarter will want to be
buried but the UK like
many Western European countries is
running out of burial space especially
in the major cities and the Greater
London Authority has been aware of this
for a while and the main causes a
population growth the fact that existing
cemeteries are almost full there's a
custom in the UK that graves are
considered to be occupied forever and
there's also development pleasure people
want to use that same land to build
houses or offices or shops so they came
up with a few solutions they were like
well maybe we can reuse those graves
after 50 years or maybe we can bury
people like four deep so that four
people can be buried in the same plot
and we can make more efficient use of
the land that way and in that way
hopefully London I'll still have space
to bury people in the near future but
traditionally cemeteries haven't been
taken care of by the local authority in
fact the surprising thing is that
there's no legal obligation on anyone in
the UK to provide burial space
traditionally it's been done by private
and religious organizations like
churches and mosques and synagogues but
there's also occasionally been a full
profit group who's wanted to get in on
the act and you know they look at sort
of the small size of a burial plot and
that high cost and it looks like the
serious money to be made so actually if
you want to go out and start your own
Cemetery you kind of can there was this
couple in South Wales and they had a
farmhouse and a load of fields next to
it and they wanted to develop the land
and they had a load of ideas they first
thought about making a caravan park but
the council said no and then they wanted
to make a fish farm and again the
council said no and then they hit on the
idea of making a cemetery and they
calculated that by doing this they could
increase the value of their land from
about ninety-five thousand pounds to
over 1 million pounds but I mean just to
come back to this idea of making profit
from cemeteries like it's kind of
ludicrous right like the thing is that
the high cost of those burial plots is
actually very misleading they look like
they're expensive but that costs
reflects the fire
but you need to maintain a burial plot
like someone has to cut the grass for
the next 50 years and that means it's
very difficult to make money from
cemeteries and it's the reason that
normally they're run by the council or
by a not-for-profit group but anyway the
council granted these people permission
and they're now trying to build their
cemetery so just to explain to you kind
of how this works if I want to build
something in the UK like a cemetery for
example then I have to apply for
planning permission first so if I want
to build like a new office building for
a client or if I want to extend my home
or you know if I have a shop and I want
to convert it into an office I have to
do a lot of drawings and I submit them
to the council for permission and
they'll look at things like how it fits
in the surroundings so they'll look at
what it looks like but they'll also
think about things like what impact is
it going to have on the local
environment and they'll be thinking
about things like you know is this thing
going to cause pollution or is there
going to be a lot of traffic that wants
to go to this thing that I've built but
also good things you know is it going to
add local services like shops to the
neighborhood that local people would
like to use and they'll wear up the
advantages and the disadvantages and
they'll make a decision so that's how it
works if I want to build a large
cemetery but what if I've got a piece of
land and I just want to bury a few
people like five or six well then
actually I don't need permission from
anyone there's actually almost no
regulation in the UK around burial and
the little bit that there is is about
not polluting water courses like not
polluting rivers or groundwater so
actually if you want to go and make your
own mini cemetery then you can but I
mean like really like who does this
right well you know if you're an artist
aquatic family and you have a large
estate then there's a chance that you'll
have a mausoleum on it and you'll bury
your family there but the really weird
thing is that you don't need to have a
piece of land of a certain size before
you're allowed to start burying people
on it and so that means that technically
this applies to like the back garden of
your house in the suburbs
so like what if you wanted to try this
yourself at home well but there's a few
councils that have guidance on their
website which can help you so the first
thing that they tell you is that you
need to have a certificate of burial
before you can go ahead you're not
allowed to just murder people and put
them under the patio and they also tell
you that you need to keep a record of
where the grave is but that's pretty
much it for formal requirements now they
do warn you that your neighbors might
not like this but legally speaking
there's almost nothing that they can do
about it and you know just in case any
of you still had that sort of profit
idea in your mind about how much those
burial plots cost and how much money you
might be able to make they also warned
that it might cause the value of your
house to drop by twenty percent although
actually it's more likely that no one
will want to buy your house at all after
that so what I find fascinating about
this is the the fact that it kind of
sums up many of our attitudes towards
death in the UK and I think that the
figures across Europe are probably
similar only about thirty percent of
people have ever talked to anyone about
their wishes around death and even for
people over 75 only forty five percent
of people have ever talked about this
and the reasons that people give you
know they think that their death is fall
off or they think that they're going to
make people uncomfortable by talking
about it and you know to a certain
extent there are other people out there
who are taking care of things for us you
know the government has all this
regulation and bureaucracy around things
like burying a death for example and
there's people like funeral directors
who devote their entire working lives to
this issue but when it comes to our
cities and thinking about how death fits
in our cities there's much less
regulation and design and thought than
we might imagine so we're not thinking
about this but all of the people that we
imagine are thinking about it they're
not taking care of it either thank you
[Applause]